Через скупчення російських військ на кордоні з Україною
тема добудови газогону "Північний потік-2"
як складова тиску на Кремль знову активно обговорюється в Німеччині.
Міністерка оборони Німеччини Аннеґрет Крамп-Карренбауер
пропонує взаємодіяти з Росією за формулою "газ в обмін на поведінку".
Тобто прив’язати можливе використання "Північного потоку-2",
якщо його таки добудують, до "поведінки Росії".
Водночас очільник німецького МЗС Гайко Маас
вважає, що відмова від будівництва може призвести до посилення
напруженості на кордоні України і Росії.
Ця труба - один з найбільших подразників у відносинах між Берліном і Вашингтоном.
Своїми санкціями американці намагаються зупинити добудову проєкту,
готового вже на понад 90 відсотків.
Суттєво сповільнити прокладку труб американцям вдалося, але остаточно
"поховати" "Північний потік-2" - поки ще ні.
Джо Байден хоче відновити добрі відносини з Німеччиною,
які суттєво погіршилися за часів Дональда Трампа,
і тому поки уникає жорсткої риторики.
"Північний потік 2" - це складна проблема, яка зачіпає
наших союзників у Європі. Я вже давно проти "Північного потоку-2".
Від самого початку, коли я ще не був на цій посаді,
й до того, як я залишив офіс віцепрезидента.
Але це все ще актуальна проблема.
Україна ж продовжує активно доводити західним партнерам,
чому від "Північного потоку-2" варто відмовитися.
У свіжому інтерв’ю французькому Le Figaro Володимир Зеленський,
який 16 квітня в Парижі обговорив ситуацію на кордонах з Макроном і Меркель,
назвав цей проєкт енергетичною війною, від якої постраждає
не лише Україна. Київ наполягає, що питання труби -
це не лише про газопостачання, але й про безпеку.
Мовляв, як тільки українська ГТС стане не потрібна Росії,
Кремль уже ніщо не стримуватиме від ймовірної нової агресії проти України.
Тим часом, вся наземна інфраструктура для "Північного потоку-2" вже готова.
Ця газокомпресорна станція за 50 кілометрів на південь від Берліна -
один з об'єктів газотранспортної системи EUGAL,
яка планувалася як наземне продовження "Північного потоку-2".
Газ повинен надходити з Росії дном Балтійського моря.
Це наочне застереження з приводу того, що інвестиції в інфраструктуру
викопних енергоносіїв пов'язані з великими фінансовими ризиками.
Тому що якщо ми всерйоз ставимося до Паризької кліматичної угоди
та міжнародних договорів зі скорочення шкідливих викидів,
то це означає, що ми будемо спалювати дедалі менше горючих копалин,
в тому числі природного газу.
Дві нитки газопроводу EUGAL тягнуться від Балтійського узбережжя Німеччини
на південь у бік кордону з Чехією. Його протяжність - 480 кілометрів.
Труби прокладені вздовж першої черги наземного продовження
"Північного потоку" - газопроводу OPAL.
Ми побудували газопровід з підключенням до "Північного потоку-2".
Але він інтегрований в німецьку і тим самим європейську газотранспортну систему.
І в нас є технічна можливість закачувати газ у трубопровід
і відбирати газ з нього в різних місцях.
Насправді ж запланована точка закачування газу не готова,
оскільки не готовий підвідний трубопровід.
Та чи буде готовий і коли - незрозуміло. У будь-якому разі
позиція США щодо "Північного потоку-2"
з приходом у Білий дім Джо Байдена не змінилася.
Що буде в такому випадку з EUGAL? Його будівництво коштувало
3 мільярди євро. 50 з половиною відсотків акцій EUGAL
належать газотранспортній компанії Gascade - це спільне підприємство
німецького BASF і "Газпрому". Gascade ж є оператором EUGAL.
А 80 відсотків його потужності заброньовані "Газпромом"
аж на 17 років наперед. На початку квітня EUGAL був повністю введений
в експлуатацію. То який газ він прокачує?
Нині EUGAL використовується для транспортування газу,
що надходить через "Північний потік-1".
І це здається дуже вдалим рішенням, оскільки дозволяє
використовувати першу чергу "Північного потоку" на повну потужність.
Адже наземне продовження "Північного потоку-1" - трубопровід OPAL -
не отримав дозволу від регулюючих органів на 100-відсоткове використання
"Газпромом". Європейські директиви зобов'язали OPAL резервувати
частину транспортних потужностей для інших постачальників газу -
і ці відсутні потужності "Газпром" використовує наразі на EUGAL.
На відміну від американської адміністрації експертка вважає,
що запуск "Північного потоку-2" - це лише питання часу. І грошей.
Я б уклала парі - на те, що "Північний потік-2" буде добудований.
Але тут варто було б уточнити: коли він буде добудований?
Для мене, наприклад, не очевидно, що будівництво буде закінчено
у першій половині 2021 року. Я припускаю, що цей процес затягнеться.
Торік по першій нитці EUGAL було прокачано 18 мільярдів кубометрів газу.
У газотранспортній компанії Gascade вважають це свідченням
затребуваності нового газогону. Але робити прогнози
про дату запуску "Північного потоку-2" там не беруться.